За життя цих малюків борються цілі бригади лікарів.
Немовлята народилися передчасно, мають критично низьку вагу,
перебувають в реанімації і потребують дороговартісних обстежень і препаратів.
Тепер їхні батьки не мусять шукати і платити десятки тисяч гривень
за порятунок новонароджених.
Принаймні у цьому перинатальному центрі міста Києва.
З 1 квітня в Україні стартував другий етап медичної реформи,
який передбачає, що все необхідне для пологів має надавати лікарня,
з якою за це розраховується держава.
Батьки тепер будуть впевнені, що допомогу дитині нададуть своєчасно і безкоштовно,
що будуть проведені усі необхідні обстеження, аналізи,
що мама та дитина отримають якісну медичну допомогу на тому ж рівні,
якби пологи відбулися в клініці за кордоном.
Кошти за кожні пологи лікарням компенсує Національна служба здоров’я України.
За природні пологи держава платить 8 200 гривень.
У випадку кесаревого розтину, передчасних пологів чи пологів з ускладненнями
передбачено компенсацію від 20 000 до майже 100 000 гривень.
На державному рівні затверджено перелік послуг, які лікарня надає породіллям і малюкам.
Так званий гарантований пакет меддопомоги передбачає оплату роботи медиків
у пологовому залі, включно з анестезію та усіма необхідними препаратами,
спільне перебування в палаті, а в разі необхідності й реанімацію.
Інформацію про своїх пацієнтів і перебіг лікування
кожна лікарня має вносити до бази даних Національної служби здоров’я.
Це нова система від НСЗУ: госпіталізація, діагноз, потім всі ці дані обробляються,
далі вони нам за кожен випадок фінансування дають.
У Перинатальному центрі Києва з дня старту другого етапу медичної реформи
вже отримали від держави 6 мільйонів гривень компенсації за пологи, які пройшли в квітні.
У центрі переконані, що принцип фінансування медзакладів, коли "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом",
для них вигідніший, ніж бюджетні дотації, які їм виділяли раніше.
Цих грошей стало більше. Тому що буде оплачуватися фактично вилікуваний випадок.
Чим більше вилікуваних випадків, тим більше функціонує стаціонар,
тим більше він отримує коштів і тим більше він може забезпечити роботу всього стаціонару.
Щоправда, така система запрацювала поки далеко не в усіх пологових будинках України.
DW вирішила поцікавитися, чи справді матусям, які народили після 1 квітня,
більше не довелося платити за пологи.
Якщо можна порівняти те, що було в 2014 році, коли я вперше народжувала,
і те, що зараз, то це відсутність списків лікарських засобів, які треба брати з собою.
З мене нічого не брали ні за палату, ні за якесь особливе ставлення,
ні за харчування. Все це було безкоштовно.
І у порівнянні з 2014-им різниця була, як на мене, разюча.
Тут 50 на 50. Комусь пощастило, на швидкій доправили для лікарні - і все чудово.
А комусь не пощастило. Є безкоштовні пологи, але є і везіння.
У громадській організації "Природні права" кажуть, що не всі жінки
готові відкрито розповідати, де, скільки та за що їм довелося платити під час пологів.
Часто жінки навіть не поінформовані про наявність такої послуги від держави
і про те, що в неї входить.
Також не усі знають, що послугу безкоштовні пологи можуть надавати лише ті лікарні,
які мають відповідний контракт з Нацслужбою здоров'я.
Частина лікарень з невідомих нам причин не підписали ці договори,
тому в них жінки не можуть розраховувати на безкоштовні пологи.
Якщо казати, як це дотримується в лікарнях, де договори підписані,
то в нас є інформація, що це відбувається
жінки іноді кажуть, що, так, дійсно, ми народжували в пологовому будинку
і наш досвід показує, що це безкоштовно.
Але при цьому є розповіді і про те, що їх просили купити якісь додаткові препарати
або просили віддячити певним чином.
З подібною ситуацією зіткнулася мешканка Запоріжжя Ярослава Чайковська.
Вона розповіла DW про свій негативний досвід з пошуку пологового будинку,
де могла б народити безкоштовно.
Це при тому, що вона спілкувалася з адміністрацією лікарні, яка має договір з НСЗУ.
Коли я спитала про те, чи є фонд, мені сказали, що фонд у 1700 гривень залишився
або дають список ліків, які потрібні.
Тому що незважаючи на реформу, вони нічого від держави не отримували і в них нічого нема.
І це в першу чергу потрібні мені
Особисто я вибрала інший пологовий, там, де навіть мені не прийшлося задавати це питання.
Просто, коли ми розмовляли з лікарем, він сам сказав, що якщо з вас хтось щось буде вимагати
в нас все є і нічого не треба купувати.
Договори з НСЗУ уклали приблизно 400 пологових будинків і лікарень України.
Загальний бюджет програми медичних гарантій на допомогу при пологах
на цей рік становить понад півтора мільярда гривень.
Лікарні, які не уклали договір з Національною службою здоров’я,
не отримуватимуть державного фінансування за програмою "Безкоштовні пологи".
Така ситуація склалася, приміром, у цьому Київському центрі
репродуктивної та перинатальної медицини.
Тут народжують жінки, в яких різні інфекційні та вірусні захворювання: ВІЛ/СНІД, гепатит тощо.
Центр відмовився підписувати договір з державою,
оскільки НСЗУ і МОЗ досі не розробили тарифів для оплати таких пологів.
Наш заклад прийняв торік 1200 пологів.
З них переважна більшість - це пологи у жінок з ускладненнями.
Тобто собівартість одних пологів у нашому закладі набагато вища, ніж 8 000 гривень.
У нас була одна дівчина, яка померла, на жаль, яка пізно звернулася з пневмонією.
Ми її лікували 60 днів. Вона померла, дитину врятували, а її не змогли.
Так-от вартість лікування такої пацієнтки в нас - більше мільйона гривень.
Люди збирали гроші, і телеканали збирали, і небайдужі…
Загалом у центрі дуже очікували медичну реформу.
І тепер сподіваються, що уряд почує їх і нарешті визначить вартість
таких особливих медичних послуг, як пологи в жінок з інфекційними захворюваннями,
і внесе їх у перелік безкоштовних послуг в рамках медичної реформи.
Аби уникнути неприємних несподіванок у пологових будинках,
захисники прав вагітних радять їм підготуватися до пологів також інформаційно:
з’ясувати, чи має лікарня контракт з Нацслужбою здоров'я
і які саме послуги в цій лікарні можна отримати безкоштовно.
У випадках, коли лікарі мають договори з НСЗУ і все одно хочуть якихось доплат,
необхідно повідомляти на гарячу лінію Національної служби здоров’я,
яка має право в таких випадках розірвати контракт з пологовим будинком.